this is the home stretch
two episodes left how are you feeling
this has got to be emotional for you
because it's been a big part of your
life for what almost a decade right yeah
yeah and i've been doing listen i've
been nearly 30 years acting so it's it's
very weird when you've when i consider
myself a strolling player
to be suddenly dragged out into the
uninvited onto wonderful shows like this
and it was i mean really i would think
for the first time in your life a really
steady gig
yeah the only time i've ever had
security in my life it's absolutely true
yeah it's true actors you're a very
talented actor but even the most
talented actors you work a couple of
months and then okay now there's a down
time for a month but this game of
thrones steady steady steady work you're
nearly losing your house on a number of
occasions because you've made artistic
decisions about things instead of
looking after your family like you're
supposed to be doing so wow it's
actually you said that with a lot of
anger
i'm bitter instead of looking after your
family the way you're supposed to
how do you uh
feel not no not telling us obviously
what happens but are you feeling good
about the game of thrones ending
it's it's kind of interesting i mean you
know in reality if we
if we got the end of the show and and
wrapped it up in a nice pink ribbon and
and closed every
story that that everybody wants i think
people
after been tested and the audience have
been tested on this i mean you know it's
there's some morally dangerous stuff we
were dealing with it's very edgy and if
we if we end of the story where
everybody's kind of happy and sorted out
and all that we would be accused of
being condescending and patronizing and
everything so i think obviously as we
can see from the last episode the big
issues are being dealt with yes and
and basically that's what
our responsibility is you know so
it's a fantastic ending it's amazing i
have to say personally
uh and i know you're a fan too andy but
i know for me personally it's just i now
watch these it's an it's an event it's
so rare that tv is an event you know and
it's so rare that
it has and and these episodes you can't
wait you can't wait and well i'll watch
it in two days when i have time because
i need to see it when everyone else is
seeing it that has i mean it doesn't
happen much anymore no and it's even
worse in my house because on the couch
there's six of us at two a.m in the
morning watch it because it's simulcast
with uh with over here and we want to
beat everybody else because i'm watching
them exactly the same time as you were
right you've probably got advanced
copies i haven't no wait what are you
getting mad again
until now i don't i don't have advan who
do you think i am
you got barack obama
i know and he lost the dvds apparently
at one stage did he really apparently
before they went out they were all
biting their nails oh i don't care he
should i should have been impeached for
that i think
he should have been taken down for that
that's ridiculous
that's where that's trump's angle now he
had the dvds and he lost him